bienvenue dans paf ça doit être le
numéro 8 et c'est déjà l'heure des
bilans puisqu'on arrive comme vous le
savez à la fin de l'année alors on va
parler de ce qui s'est passé des grands
événements qui sont passés cette année
ce qu'on peut en penser qu'est-ce que
ils peuvent nous apporter pour l'année
qui vient et on va en parler avec
Sephora Dahmani
ce soir ce soir deux semaines de
vacances mais qui se constitueuses
pour la 8e
Jean-Luc Madec bonjour Patrice super le
restaurant marche bien le problème
Florence Mercadet
ils sont pas contents
je suis extrêmement confiant alors on va
aborder quelques années des sujets de
l'année évidemment il y a la politique
et la politique qui a été marquée par la
défaite de la gauche aux municipales par
le fait que le Front National est devenu
le premier parti de France aux Européens
par la reconquête du Sénat par la droite
est-ce que à votre avis on assiste au
fond à une droiteisation de la société
on pourrait ajouter le succès de de
livres comme le livre d'Éric Zemmour sur
le suicide le suicide français est-ce
que votre avis mon assiste à une
droitisation de la société non moi je
pense pas qu'il y a une droiteisation je
pense que le pays est fondamentalement à
droite depuis très longtemps donc de
temps en temps il passe à gauche pour
des raisons
il avait totalement raison donc après
elle passe pas fondamentalement à droite
que elle l'est et puis après je pense
que ce qui disparaît probablement c'est
bipolarisation droite-gauche
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des sujets qui
sont on peut être de supposer de droite
et trouver que la gauche fait parfois
des trucs intéressants et inversement
donc c'est ça quoi que on échappe
justement à ce clivage terrible aura de
gauche et voilà c'est c'est ça qui se
termine je pense
maintenant je sais plus très bien ce que
ça veut dire que droite est-ce que ça
veut dire que gauche je sais qu'il y a
des extrêmes ça je sais à peu près les
situer mais je pense qu'il y a une
recomposition et une réflexion aussi
dans le dans le paysage qui soit de
façon générale à droite ou à gauche mais
la droite encore je pense qu'il se il se
cherche un peu et je pense surtout qu'il
y a une réaction des Français qui a une
façon qui sont plutôt réactionnaires non
pas au sens politique du terme au sens
chimique c'est-à-dire qu'il y a eu une
réaction on a voté majoritairement
contre de Monsieur Sarkozy et là on va
contre
et
donc on est plus voilà et donc là cette
année en 2014 je pense que ils ont voté
contre François Hollande donc
votre compte voilà
je pense qu'il y a une évolution un peu
de toutes les sociétés ou avant on avait
des marqueurs forts et fixes et que là
aujourd'hui tout est un peu mouvant
le score du Front national qui est quand
même voilà quand même le premier parti
de France aux européennes Jean-Luc Malak
je pense que la plus grande défaite en
fait c'est la défaite de la démocratie
le taux d'abstention aux élections est
absolument abominable là on atteint plus
de 2/3 de nos concitoyens qui se
déplacer c'est 67
donc la défaite c'est la défaite de
l'alimentation alors oui bien entendu
c'est vrai que la France est plutôt
conservatrice que de droite que c'est
droit de gauche on sait jamais remis
nous d'avoir guillotine et Louis XVI et
nous n'avons jamais cessé
de recréer de rebâtir soit des rois nos
présidents sont des rois quelque part
soit des systèmes aristocratiques nous
sommes aujourd'hui avec nos
administrations dans un système de
l'aristocrat administratif c'est
absolument terrifiant moi pour ma part
le grand vœu que j'ai pour 2015 c'est
que nous puissions redevenir un pays
démocratique comme la démocratie est-ce
que c'est des fêtes de la démocratie ou
des fêtes de la classe politique ou des
fêtes de dirigeants politiques classe
politique n'est pas en démocratie
nous ne sommes plus dans un pays
démocratique nous sommes dans un pays
qui va à volo avait d'ailleurs une
certaine forme de dictature de la pensée
ce qui est extrêmement grave la pensée
unique ça touche tout le monde je crois
donc non la grande défaite c'est
démocratie il est temps qu'on se
réveille
ça va alors je sais pas s'il y a une
droiteisation après tout droitisation
également il y a le mot droite
tellement de droite que visiblement il y
en a qui prennent
leurs rêves pour des réalités
probablement que vous êtes toujours
entouré par les mêmes personnes
simplement j'en rencontre d'autres qui
sont plutôt marqués à gauche et qui font
notamment fondamentalement aux pensées
que la France était à gauche à une
époque et qu'elle rebasculera
probablement encore à droite je sais pas
c'est de la droitisation par contre ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'il y a une
économisation je vais pas t'inventer un
mot ou je sais pas si ça se dit les
littéraires d'en face
j'y suis pas encore mais c'est propre à
la gauche peut-être de créer en tous les
cas donc l'économisation c'est-à-dire
que
je pense que il y a un vrai glissement
alors que l'on dit vers la droite
c'est-à-dire que même même le Parti de
Gauche
glisse vers la sociale démocratie ou
vers la sociale libéralisation avec des
marqueurs de qui sont les marqueurs de
droite et quand on pense que finalement
à droite l'aurait rêvé c'est à dire que
quand on parle de libéralisation ou
quand on parle de dérégulation c'était
des propos qui étaient déjà engagés à
l'époque par la droite donc ouais on
peut parler de droitisation économique
de plus en plus on a des marqueurs
économiques qui ont tendance à nous
emmener de ce côté de l'échiquier
politique l'extrême gauche étant à peu
près à peu près maintenant
circonscrites à très très peu de choses
et puis plus de plus en plus à droite
jusqu'au l'extrême droite effectivement
l'extrême droite
sauf que le ce qui gonfle le parti en
électeur d'extrême droite c'est souvent
des gens de gauche et on dira aussi que
l'extrême droite a souvent gonflé ces
exécutives dans les périodes de crise
économique donc on a une crise
économique on a un glissement économique
et on a une glyclisation si je peux me
permettre
ce qui s'est passé jusqu'à présent c'est
qu'il y avait une alternance voter à
gauche
ça s'est passé un peu comme ça là on
n'est plus on est plus on est plus
quand le Front national devient le
premier parti de France on est plus dans
l'alternance classique entre la gauche
républicaine de la droite républicaine
on est dans un autre sphère c'est le
piège de l'apprenti sorcier c'est c'est
François Hollande qui est tombé dedans
vraiment comme comme un débutant
c'est-à-dire que à vouloir faire monter
Front national bah ça effectivement
c'est le
nouveau ça dépasse ça dépasse
l'entendement il n'a pas arrêté de
vouloir couper la France en quatre puis
en 8 faire des sujets de société là où
il y avait même pas de débats de créer
de créer des des décisions dans chaque
famille dans chaque chose il pousse les
gens à voteront national à être
complètement
déboussolée par une société qui s'est
absolument pu puis où elle va alors les
gens pouvaient accepter éventuellement
le fait de pas avoir de boulot mais si
on leur dit qu'en plus la famille c'est
fini que la société c'est plus qu'elle
devrait être que de toute façon tout est
fait pour que pour repousser les gens
alors les gens très intéressants
le Front national il pouvait peut-être
des bonnes questions la porte des
réponses exécrables on est tout à fait
d'accord mais il y a des tonnes
des gens sur le mariage pour tous on l'a
fait avec le
contre-sangré de Florent Philippe si le
Front national n'a pas pris de position
très très tranchée on peut comprendre
aussi pourquoi Sephora
à vouloir chercher la réponse autre part
mais voilà et après c'est vrai on est un
pays libéral donc ça je pense que c'est
un mode de contestation en tout cas il y
a eu donc cette défaite de la gauche aux
municipales qui a entraîné des
changements notamment dans les
municipalités dans les communautés
d'agglomération également ça a été le
cas évidemment à Saint-Quentin
l'agglomération 50-hinoise bascule à
droite une première depuis sa création
en 1973 à l'issue de ce second tour des
municipal 25 sièges échouent aux
candidats qui portent les couleurs de la
droite et 23 à ceux qui portent les
couleurs de la gauche et ce alors que
les communes conservent leur couleur
politique lui en cours trap et Manille
lamour reste socialiste la verrière
communiste Élancourt demeure UMP
Montigny divers droites et Alexandra
Rosetti udi emporte voisin le Bretonneux
quatre villes à gauche trois villes à
droite une particularité qui va influer
le sur le mode de gouvernance comme
l'estimait Michel Laugier le maire de
Montigny dimanche soir sur notre plateau
on a beaucoup d'atouts à Saint-Quentin
on a beaucoup d'Atos 50 ans moi je
souhaite surtout que justement que cette
agglomération soit surtout un outil pour
les pour les communes et qu'on réussisse
ensemble et pas que ce soit comme ça a
été il y a même pas mal de temps un
outil plus politicien en direction de
certaines formations politiques tout
simplement donc là moi aujourd'hui je
suis pour plus de clarté plus de
transparence et effectivement que tout
le monde soit associé on a cette
nouvelle gouvernance a inventée je pense
malgré tout collectivement même si ça
sera à la charge de celui qui ou de
celle visiblement celui qui sera la tête
de lagglomération de faire des
propositions mais forcément il faudra
inventer quelque chose pour réussir à
sortir de cette situation un peu étrange
ou effectivement quatre villes de gauche
peuvent être avec trois villes de droite
et avec une majorité quand même de
sièges pour la droite
l'agglomération 50 chinoise à droite
c'est une révolution politique certes
mais pas tant que cela car les écarts
entre la droite et la gauche ont
toujours été serrés par exemple pendant
les 16 années de gouvernance de Robert
kadalbert la répartition était de 22
sièges pour la gauche et 20 pour la
droite
la différence entre un projet de gauche
de droite on le sait on sait ce que
c'est effectivement un projet où on
accueille pour tout le monde et mixité
sociale des services publics de qualité
bon on connaît les grands fondements
entre la gauche et à droite mais sinon
moi je suis sûr que les élus quels
qu'ils soient la direction de
Saint-Quentin ils ont envie que ça
continue et que ça continue à réussir à
50 ans Yvelines il faudra encore
patienter plusieurs jours pour connaître
le nom du futur président de la
Communauté d'Agglomération attendre déjà
l'installation des conseils municipaux à
Trappes et à Voisins-le-Bretonneux le
nouveau conseil communautaire doit se
réunir avant le 30 avril
voilà donc changement de majorité à
Saint-Quentin Michel dolier président de
la casquille en remplacement de Roberta
d'Albert est-ce que Florence par exemple
sont déjà des changements est-ce que
vous avez senti des mots ce que c'est la
même chose qu'avant en fait non sur le
terrain je suis pas sûr que ça se
ressent tout de suite parce que c'est un
peu trop tôt mais je sais qu'au niveau
par exemple de la Maison de l'Entreprise
il y a des déjà enfin Robert kahlbert
était très proche des entreprises et
œuvrer beaucoup pour les entreprises et
là maintenant la nouvelle majorité je
crois va encore plus vite avec des
objectifs peut-être plus plus ambitieux
en tout cas mais vraiment elle est très
très attentive à l'accélération du
développement économique de notre
territoire
moi ça serait plutôt sur le plan des
associations au niveau des associations
alors je serai pas définitif pour dire
qu'il y a un vrai changement ça fait
trop peu de temps qu'ils sont là mais
clairement ils ont un réflexe qui me
paraît à peu près sain c'est de nous
écouter déjà donc on est ils sont à
l'écoute et en même temps je pense que
c'est le sport il semblerait que ça soit
une valeur plus un marqueur de droite en
tout cas c'est comme ça qu'il le
perçoivent avec cette notion de voilà le
sport la notion d'engagement les
objectifs ça rejoindrait presque
l'entreprise en tout cas jusqu'à
maintenant il y a une écoute il y a une
tendance favorable donc du changement
suivant absolument
une des conséquences évidemment de la
défaite de la gauche aux municipale ça a
été le changement à la tête du
gouvernement le remplacement de
Jean-Marc Ayrault par Manuel Valls un an
après à peu près non pas encore tout à
fait non enfin quelques 9 mois après
comment comment vous le jugez
tout réussite ou plutôt
je parle pas de la politique qui mène je
parle de son image je parle il est assez
séduisant même si des dernière mangent
au journal télévisé je trouve qu'il
s'est lamentablement effondré quoi il a
été très mauvais face
je pense qu'ils ont un vrai problème de
communication ce gouvernement
c'est-à-dire que tout ce qui est bien
ils arrivent à le massacrer enfin j'ai
regardé dès qu'ils font quelque chose il
y a un petit événement qui vient
annihiler tout ce qui a été tenté et là
vasque plutôt une bonne image
effectivement sans parler du fond que tu
es plutôt dynamique plutôt agréable et
qui paraissait beaucoup moins sectaire
qu'on avait pu le croire etc là tout
d'un coup il se il semble s'effondrer
alors c'est mon avis je dois être le
seul à le partager parce qu'il a
l'impression on a l'impression qu'il
remonte un peu dans les sondages
plus les mauvais à la télévision
je pense que le garçon n'est pas à la
hauteur de la tâche quoi tout ça
il y a bon un garçon là qu'ils ont
essayé de monter Macron qui va leur
servir de fusible puisque finalement
c'est lui qui porte sur son nom les
vrais réformes qu'il faut faire dans ce
pays il est bien évident que il va être
probablement massacré d'ici quelques
semaines et que les réformes qu'il
préconisent il le restera à peine 10%
c'est bien dommage mais il faut un
fusible comme visiblement Manuel Valls
n'a pas envie de servir de fusible parce
qu'il a des ambitions à long terme et
bien c'est Macron qui va trinquer quoi
dommage alors on parlait on parlait de
Kero héros versus versus Vans bah pour
moi c'est un changement de style c'est
un changement de méthode c'est on va
dire deux capitaines d'équipe qui qui se
succèdent donc il y a une méthode on
voit bien que c'est beaucoup plus
dynamisme c'est beaucoup plus gros c'est
beaucoup plus hermétique c'est beaucoup
plus on va dire musclé pour le reste il
y a des il y a des choses qui sont mises
sur la table attendons de voir moi je
j'ai pas le sentiment que c'est beaucoup
bougé hormis lui même il y a
effectivement plus de dynamisme mais
pour le coup il y a des choses qui ont
été avancées elles ont pas porté leurs
effets moi les lois Macron par exemple
c'est juste que j'ai l'habitude je sais
ce que c'est qu'une loi on est une
avocate avec nous qui pourrait nous le
rappeler mais c'est vrai qu'une loi pour
moi c'est la loi sur un élément sur un
fait société c'est ça une loi là une loi
avec
moderniser donc voilà c'est quasiment le
programme de landes
à Bruxelles donc on est sur le budget
donc c'est regarder tout ce qu'on fait
vis-à-vis de Bruxelles alors moi par
rapport aux deux je trouve que je pense
que Jean-Marc Ayraud était un
collaborateur de François Hollande et
que Emmanuel Valls et chef de
gouvernement
le Premier ministre Premier ministre
d'un président de la République est
toujours plus proche de lui on prend
plutôt c'est ceux qui sont proches
c'est parce qu'effectivement ça agace
tout simplement c'est que les choses
sont frappés que Sarkozy sont numéro 2
à mon avis c'est parce qu'il y a du bon
sens chez les Français c'est que c'est
pas tranché tout simplement c'est-à-dire
que l'affaire que P c'est quand même une
affaire on a vu émerger allez on va pas
l'employer des mots définitifs mais des
magouilles au sein au sein de au sein du
parti au niveau de la comment dire
l'économie du de l'UMP au niveau
j'en oublie l'affaire Bygmalion et à un
moment donné ça a été tranché pour les
Français alors c'est pas tranché pour la
justice c'est ce qu'on dira ils sont
présumés
quasiment pour les Français et le fait
de les voir réapparaître c'est une
manière de dire ça nous agace c'est
tranché dans l'esprit des Français pour
coper ça l'était quasiment pour Sarkozy
et ce retour en force bah ça agace
d'autant plus qu'il revient pas comme
l'homme providentiel qu'on souhaite et
rêve notre ami Jean-Luc l'homme
providentiel qui viendra avec des
valeurs qui viendra avec des fondements
qui viendrait qu'une politique à mettre
en place mais qui revient par des
histoires de de fauteuil par des
histoires encore une fois la politique à
l'UMP qui agace mais c'est pas mon point
de vue encore une fois j'essaye de
décrypter cette tête à claques
Sarkozy facile parce que c'est pas une
sorte de pleine nous qu'on pose là
devant un écran de télévision et qui
vient nous nous délivrer un discours
convenu qu'on a tous entendu c'est vrai
qu'il a un côté horripilant il est
toujours agité il est toujours dans un
peu dans la démesure mais c'est ce qui
fait que il fascine autant qu'il agace
et que après il faut il faut pas il faut
pas l'intérêt
comme ça
il a pas changé donc les gens l'ont
exclu
on dit reviens avec le même moi j'ai dit
heureusement qu'il a pas changé j'ai pas
envie qu'il change
de Gaulle en 58 avait pas changé
pourtant l'ami dehors à coup de pont
pour 48 excusez-moi donc voilà l'homme
providentiel je sais pas où il est c'est
peut-être Sarkozy ou un autre je n'en
sais rien en tous les cas il a il a sur
lui la trace terrible d'année et d'année
de médiatisation contre Sarkozy bon
voilà c'est triste dans la liste des
politiques moi je trouve incroyable que
nous n'ayons pas cité un type comme
Cahuzac qui alors la caricature du monde
mais c'est terrifiant dans la catégorie
dans la catégorie à ce niveau et et et
moi je m'interroge et je trouve ça
extrêmement difficile je on devrait pas
s'interroger sur des sujets pareils à la
veille de Noël mais en même temps tu
devrais pas passer Cahuzac tu es venu on
était sorti parce que Mediapart a réussi
à faire la démonstration de leur
malhonnêteté absolue j'espère qu'il n'y
en a pas d'autres c'est ça qui m'effraie
alors ça ça pourrait être un coup de
gueule je voudrais qu'on passe beaucoup
de gueule vos coups de cœur de l'année
pardon qu'est-ce qui vous a voilà
qu'est-ce que vous a réjoui parce qu'il
faut être un peu positif quand même
qu'est-ce qui vous a réduit dans cette
année Sephora moi c'était un événement
que j'attendais la réouverture du musée
Picasso sur Paris c'est un très bon
musée magnifique je vous invite tous à
aller visiter et la collection est très
riche
pour cette année c'est François et ses
ministres mais pour le coup François
François le pape François voilà la
conclusion du Synode j'ai trouvé ça très
impressionnant ce qui avait été dit à ce
moment-là et puis le discours le
discours à Bruxelles voilà on a là un
pape alors hormis le fait que ça soit
emprunté
que ça soit très voilà le pape le
représentant des chrétiens au Parlement
voilà un petit peu offusqué pour ma part
j'ai vraiment entendu voilà un homme un
grand homme et dire des choses de
politique générale avec des fondements
des valeurs quelque chose qui aurait pu
être emprunté par beaucoup de politiques
j'ai trouvé ça très très fort et puis ce
synode qui se conclut sur ben oui il y a
des ouvertures c'est vrai qu'il y a des
choses à revisiter et dans cette période
très troublée
alors pour le coup très troublé sur le
plan
voilà sur le plan mondial on parle du
pape et à contrario on a toute cette
image dégradé de Parlement par le biais
de l'islamisation sur l'islam versus la
chrétiente
totalement la vie de Mustapha à propos
du pape François
il est un homme hors du commun nous en
avons besoin
c'est un milliard d'individus quand même
qui sont aujourd'hui influencés par la
position du pape et il fait confiance en
l'intelligence humaine face à la
barbarie or depuis que le monde existe
les grandes civilisations ont toutes été
anéanties par la barbarie je ne citerai
pas toutes les civilisations mais vous
connaissez votre histoire comme moi et
je pense qu'aujourd'hui où nous sommes
dans une civilisation où on a tendance à
aller vers la bêtise le pape François
fait la promotion de l'intelligence moi
je dis bravo c'est le peuple qui aime le
foot en plus
alors moi ce qui m'a fasciné cette année
c'est le voyage dans l'espace de Rosetta
et
parce que partir enfin c'est
inimaginable quoi ça fait 10 ans qu'elle
est en route
il y a 10 ans mais 10 ans de voyage ça
c'est autre chose que dans le temps
médiatique
extrêmement importante où elle part de
notre petite planète pour arriver
quelque part 10 ans plus tard au but où
elle devait aller en plus et où elle va
larguer où elle va larguer le petit
robot Fidea qui va arriver et qui va
atterrir pas atterrir
du monde avec ce côté alors qu'on est
tous dans la finitude et que c'est tous
un peu notre question
là c'est c'est magnifique et puis c'est
en même temps voilà ça fait rêver
moi c'est le le retour de centaines de
milliers de gens presque de millions de
gens dans les librairies oui bah oui
avec trois livres dont on pourrait
discuter de différents intérêts il y a
Trierweiler il y a Zemmour et puis le
prix Nobel de littérature a Modiano et
qui tout
tout édition confondu et tout format
confondu c'est c'est quasiment un
million et demi de gens qui sont allés
dans les librairies pour acheter ces
bouquins
record de vente et le record de gens qui
ne le disent pas voilà mais c'est parce
que c'est plus compliqué à lire que tout
ce que la presse en a dit c'est donc
c'est plus intelligible
merci merci infiniment à tous les cinq
c'est passé assez vite enfin c'est
compliqué de faire le bilan d'une année
on est encore le nez un peu sur le
guidon mais on va peut-être prendre un
peu de hauteur pour la prochaine
émission on va essayer de parler un
petit peu de ce qui va se passer en 2015
donc je vous donne rendez-vous très vite
pour un nouveau poste